Not the best idea if you're scared of heights.
This slide on the side of LA's tallest building...
...has been open to the public,...
...1,000 feet above the streets.
The exciting attraction clings to the outside of the US Bank Tower...
...and is part of the OUE Skyspace LA observation deck.
Thrill seekers will be able to sit down...
...and slide for 45 feet to an outdoor platform on the 69th floor.
According to the building's owner, Singapore-based OUE Limited,...
...the glass on the fully enclosed slide is only one and a quarter inches thick,...
...but can withstand hurricane-force winds...
...and even a powerful earthquake.
We're still not sure, but it is definitely one quick exit from the office.